So let's look at a real example of a hierarchical predictor.
We will look at Intel's Pentium M processor which has these predictors.
First it has a cheap predictor that contains just two bit counters.
Then it has a local history predictor and a global history predictor.
So what the processor is doing is it has a large array of two bit counters,
a local history predictor that stores the local history for
each branch, and an array of two bit counters for different histories. And
the global history predictor with the global history that is
longer than the local history is here. And also, an array of counters for
that predictor. So, if we try to predict a single branch, what we would do is,
we would look up the PC for the branch in the two bit counter array.
We would also try to look up the local predictor and
the global predictor prediction. And then, we form the actual prediction for
the processor by using the result of the global predictor if the global
predictor says that the branch is predicted here. And for that, what we do is we
keep another array here that is just saying whether this branch, so this is kind
of a like a tag array that says whether this branch is going to be predicted by
the global predictor. If the global predictor does not have a matching tag,
that means that this branch was not inserted in the global predictor,
in which case we shouldn't use it. If that happens, we will use the prediction
from the local predictor, which will also have a dagger A that
says whether this predictor should be predicted by the local predictor, and
if so then we use that. Otherwise, if the branch is not in the local predictor,
we just use the result of the two bit counter. When we update the predictor,
however, what we do is we update the two bit counter.
If we have the branch in the local predictor, we update the local predictor.
If we have the branch in the global predictor, we update the global predictor.
But then what happens is if we are using the two bit counter and
the branch is not in the local predictor, then what we do is if the two bit
counter is mispredicting the branch, we insert it into the local predictor. So
now the branch will be present here next time.
If the local predictor is not giving us good prediction for this branch, then we
insert the branch into the global predictors. So what's going to happen is
pretty much branches that are almost perfectly predictable by two bit counters,
and that's a lot of branches. For example every, always taken branch or
branch that is dominantly taken is going to be mostly predicted by the two
bit predictor. So we never even consult the local and global predictors. And
that save space in this predictors for other branches that need them.
Saving space means that we can have fewer of the two bit entries and
the history entries than we would otherwise need if we were trying to
predict all the branches with the local or
even the global predictor. So how do we say whether the branch is present or
not? Well, what we really do is we insert some bits of the branches address
into the corresponding line of the predictor. So the history,
entry here we will index with some bits of the PC to find the history.
And in that same entry we will also insert some of the upper bits of the PC, so
that different branches that map to this entry only one of them gets to be
predicted by this entry. The rest of them say that they're not found here.
So the idea is that if most of the branches that end up
mapping to this entry are really predictable by the two bit predictor,
then we don't really need to use this entry for those branches.